the heading today is the derivatives of
motion can I get a show of hands how
many of you currently study physics and
up one two and a half two and a half
okay so it has that most of you
therefore are in the same boat I was in
in years 11 and 12 which is that I also
did not study physics and so a lot of
this you have like the very basics of it
from frankly from year 7 to 10 like
you've learned some physics even if we
didn't call it that stuff moves around
as soon as you start to study that kind
of thing you're studying physics even if
you don't give it that big scary label
okay now we're going to dig into the
mathematical side of that there are some
distinctions to make so if you feel like
ah this is why I this is why I didn't
study physics okay don't worry we're
going to be addressing it from a side
which is hopefully very familiar based
on what we'll be laying over the last
couple weeks so let's remember when you
have an original function you can
differentiate it once you get the first
review um geometrically by the way like
on the graph what does the first
derivative tell you what does it tell
you about the shape of the graph
remember it tells you that the gradient
right very good so this tells me is it
is it going up is it going down is it is
it going up steeply or shallowly or like
kind of thing shallow leads I don't work
anyway
first derivative gives you gradient
second - if you differentiate again it
gives you a different geometric feature
namely seismicity concavity right so
this is not about are you going up
you're going down but how is you're
going up or down this how is that
changing it's how much the first
derivative is changing just like the
first derivative is how much the
original function is changing okay now
what we talked about for example
gradient right when we say the gradient
is zero like that's a special kind of
point on a graph we use a very
particular one we've said over and over
again we call that a stationary point
right and this is actually language the
idea of stationary is language that we
borrow from motion stationary means
you're not moving anywhere right which
is to say your gradient is neither up
nor down you just sitting at a at a spot
and not not going anywhere okay
so what we want to do is unpack like
this is not vo
we kind of idea that we can tack on to
this in fact all the way through we can
understand motion with a handful of new
notation and a few different concepts
that we need to apply to our existing
knowledge okay so the first thing is
when it comes to an original function we
normally say well where where is your
object that's moving where is its
position the main word that we use for
that is displacement so if you have some
starting position displacement is how
far have you gone from that starting
position like are you above or below
your starting position are you left your
right that kind of thing
okay now there's gonna be a little bit
weird it's part of why I deliberately
didn't introduce it last time we had
this table we normally say y equals some
function of X when it comes to
displacement we actually say that
position where you are we actually
denote that with an X which means that
while Y is usually your vertical axis
when you're talking about motion X is
your vertical axis almost always which
is a little bit weird and it's why I
didn't want to confuse things before but
now you've spend enough time on this
hopefully we can now get comfortable the
new idea okay
so displacement we denote that with an X
now when we go down to the next level
right well we then differentiate we're
not differentiating with respect to X X
is the function X is in fact usually a
function of where is when is based on
when right so we would say it's a
function of time T for time T's a funny
little letter because it's useful for
all kinds of things like say temperature
and that kind of thing but you will find
it most frequently refers to time and so
I'm going to even write that down for
you so you know when you come back to
these notes you like up that's what that
T stands for okay now since we've got a
function at our time we're going to
differentiate with respect to time so
when I ask the question like how's your
position how's your displacement
changing as time changes if you think
back to this triangle do you remember
this triangle that you met in like oh it
must have been your eighth or u9 when
you were studying basic motion what are
the three bits in this triangle
time distance and speed which one is
which but is it all go what's the top
which it sits in it's generally distance
right distance and then I think you got
s on the Left yep speed in time so we
would say speed is distance over time
right and in fact even the units of
speed kind of suggest this to you if you
say km/h you can see that's distance on
the top and then time on the bottom okay
now we're gonna be a little more
specific given speed we use the word
velocity and we'll distinguish between
these in a little more detail in a
second but the key thing is like if
you're thinking that the gradient you're
going up you're going down you're really
thinking about the velocity of this
object that's moving about okay so see
how we've got dy on DX over here this is
going to be think we've got something
quite different over here right look at
your variables okay what I'm
differentiating is X with respect to
time so this is a DT over here right so
DX 1 DT we would say that this is its
some get sometimes just actually just
denoted with a V for velocity right and
because you'll see this fairly
frequently you know how we've got this -
notation for derivatives right F - f
double dash and so on when you are
differentiating with respect to time
because this is something happens so
frequently it gets its own notation it's
not super common but you'll see it so I
want you to know what it means it's an X
because that's what you started with
instead of using a dot - rather we use a
dot right over the top it's right in the
center okay so velocity is how
displacement is changing over time DX on
DT sometimes questions will say hey work
out V formula and they will assume you
know that means velocity and equally
they'll also see you'll see this
notation - which means differentiate X
do it once with respect to time okay
all right so we went from displacement
to velocity now if I like I did before
differentiate one more time I'm thinking
about how is not displacement changing
over time how is velocity changing over
time like if you were seeing a car for
example you could hit the accelerator
and that would change your velocity we
increase it or you could hit the brakes
and that would also change your velocity
it would decrease it you would hope
right so what's the name for that in
fact that pedal that you're putting on
it's the acceleration right so that's
the name that we apply to the change in
velocity the only difference is this
word acceleration in the context of
mathematics is a little more technical
in specific you ever I said you've got
the accelerator pedal and then you got
the brake pedal right and we think of
those as two different things but in
fact if acceleration is any change in
velocity do you say that the brake pedal
is also changing your velocity so it's
also acceleration just of a different
kind that makes sense so I'm you'll
sometimes hear the word deceleration and
I'm very very consciously not going to
use that word because it it starts to
get confusing acceleration and I'm gonna
write this because it's such a weird
nuance it's any change in velocity if
the velocity is increasing or if the
velocity is decreasing
both of those are acceleration it's any
change in velocity okay so let's think
about how we write this okay the first
thing is I actually should have written
V first but I'm gonna write fix it up
here acceleration is sometimes just
denoted with an a we try to avoid it as
much as we can because we know we use a
for all kinds of other things right poor
Pythagoras so a is not as common but you
will see it and you need to know in the
context of a motion question they'd be
in acceleration remember I said it's
what happens when you differentiate
velocity right so yeah I could write it
as DV over DT right you take this thing
V and you differentiate it with respect
to time okay
but since V is its own derivative what
we're really looking at is the second
derivative of the thing you started up
at the top with right so I could write
that another way of writing exactly the
same thing d squared what's on the top
and look it's X right that's weird and
what's on the bottom everything's with
respect to time so I'm gonna get a DT
squared down the bottom okay
now there is one last invitation that
you're gonna use enough I've kind of
hung it on the end here right you know
how you saw that dot now it's a bit like
a - it means differentiate once instead
of with respect to exit to respect a
time well if I wanted to do it again
then instead of having an X with 1 dot
you'd have an X with two dots that means
differentiate twice who either respect a
time and it looks a bit like a weird
uncomfortable emoji but don't ever think
it so much okay so this is our extension
to think about the original function
first derivative second derivative this
is what it looks like when you're in the
land of motion okay now before we leave
off I'm gonna give us an example
question we're going to work through
here because it's like the theory
doesn't make much instance you look at
an actual situation we do have to and if
you've got space on your page maybe draw
an arrow down from the velocity box draw
it down to the bottom we just need to
make a few small notes on this this
velocity here DX 1 DT V X dot it's what
we call instantaneous velocity you know
how we first learned about gradient you
know years and years ago but then when
we went to the derivative we said
gradient is over like an interval right
you've got rise over run rise everyone
ok but the difference with these
derivatives and stuff like that is that
you're you're run do you remember like
think back to first principles your run
is kind of like zero right it's like at
a single point which is kind of weird
right because no run well here in terms
of our displacement in time a single
point is about an instant in time that's
how we call it instantaneous velocity
okay so it's varsity at an instant now
we need to distinguish this with average
velocity and you're gonna see this
language used and they sound similar
because they're connected average
velocity is still about comparing
displacement and time but it's not at an
instant it's over a period of time right
I
we would say over an interval okay so I
will say here's a start time he's an end
time not at like one single instant one
single moment it's over say an hour or
over five seconds or something like that
okay now remember I said before that
we're using this word velocity rather
than speed okay the difference with the
velocity is that just like everything
else here it includes direction so you
can have positive or negative which
might mean up and down or it might mean
left and right or forward and backward
it could it could mean anything
depending on the situation okay now when
you compare that to speed how many of
you are on your ELLs already already
pays for that matter how many of you
okay great okay so you sat in the car
you've looked hopefully at your
speedometer right now when you start
going faster you see the dial heading up
and then if you for example we're
parking and you put your current to
reverse right what happens to this speed
speedometer it still goes up right
you're like oh now I'm going ten case
per hour backwards speed your
speedometer doesn't care which way you
are going whether you going forwards or
backwards so speed doesn't include
direction it's a foot for the small
number of physics people in the room
right that's why we call it a scalar
quantity okay it doesn't include
direction velocity and displacement and
acceleration here what we call vectors
so they care whether you're going
forwards or backwards if you had a
velocity meter in your car it wouldn't
just have zero to whatever I think mine
goes like 220 or something like that not
like my Corolla could ever grow that
fast it doesn't just go positively it
might also go negatively if you were
going in Reverse okay so you've got
velocity instantaneously on average and
you also have spam then we'll come back
to the implication is that a little
later on we need to have a look at an
example